who are my greatest mentors so I got a
great question for my YouTube viewers
love you guys David wrote in to say who
are some of your greatest mentors Evan
any other industry leaders you know
personally and recommend us following
this is a great question and I believe
I'm modeling success so I love looking
at what people have already done and
modeling what worked for them and
bringing it to my business that helps
save my business when I was first
starting out and to many entrepreneurs
try to just do everything themselves and
figure everything out themselves where
if you understand that you're not the
first person trying to solve whatever
problem you're going through in your
business or personal life that other
people have gone through the same thing
and they found solutions the easiest way
to accomplish your goal is to find
someone who's already done it understand
how they did it and make it work for you
maybe with a few tweaks along the way so
I love while in success I have a lot of
mentors on the business and personal
side I'm assuming David wants to know
about the business ones and so here are
my top three for you
the first is AP Giannini an AP Giannini
is a founder of Bank of America and you
may be thinking a banker what Evan
really a banker is your favorite
entrepreneur but what I learned from him
is to stand up for the little guy and
that's what I love doing right he
believed he was a believer and he
believed in people and I believe in
entrepreneurs when he first got it
started in the banking industry he was a
director at a bank he wasn't in the
banking industry had a different
business he sold it became a director at
a bank and he said you know what guys we
need to be offering loans to to
immigrants who are hard working and
entrepreneurs we need to give them money
to they deserve a chance to succeed and
the banks had no lend to immigrants lend
to startup entrepreneurs you kidding me
we're not gay that's too risky we're not
going to do that so he left that bank
set up shop across the street
created his own Bank and he started
lending money to people who were in need
who are hardworking ability to get paid
back who were to high risk for the other
banks to pay attention to one of my
favorite stories though is when there
was this huge earthquake in San
Francisco where he was from there was a
big fire
it devastated the whole city and
people's buildings were just totally
gone and a lot of the bank's burned down
to an AP Jeanne's Bank burned down and
this is a time when people needed their
money right you need your money you got
to rebuild your life you need to buy
food to live and most of the banks they
closed down because they didn't have a
building anymore how can they be in
operation and what it be Geneva did was
his bank had been down but whatever he
took two barrels took a plank across it
brought out a wheelbarrow which had
money in it and started lending people
money on the street and he would make a
loan based on a handshake and a look in
the person's eye and trusted that they
would repay him are you kidding me who
does that
it's crazy no banker would do that but
eepa Giannini did that and that's how he
was able to build up one of the biggest
companies in the world obviously he's
way past you know living but those are
the roots
he lent money to Walt Disney to create
motion pictures and to create Disneyland
when when people said you're crazy a
full feature cartoon a huge theme park
this is a stupid idea
he lent the money to create the Golden
Gate Bridge when people thought it was a
ridiculous venture he believed in the
little guy he believed in entrepreneurs
and so that's why I love him in his
store even though most people have never
even heard of him and Bank of America
quite honestly does such a terrible job
now of recalling their own history and
sharing this great story with people my
number two mentor is Steve Jobs and
Steve Jobs recently passed away and he
had a tremendous impact on me and how I
saw my business and how I market myself
and standing for something important you
know Steve Jobs didn't want to just
create computers he wanted to make a
dent in the universe and I want to help
a billion entrepreneurs and I want that
to be not just about making money but
about having a
impact right Steve Jobs was a
multi-millionaire in his 22 could have
done anything he wanted but he worked
till the day he died building Apple and
it became the most valuable company in
the world even though he didn't his goal
wasn't money his goal wasn't money and
Apple became the number one most
valuable company in the world and
there's one video in particular that
left a lasting mark on me and I still
watch it at least once a week it's that
great a video for me at least it's on my
channel if you'd search my channel Steve
Jobs and marketing you'll find it I
think every entrepreneur needs to see
this every student who's in school and
is learning about marketing needs to see
it had a tremendous impact on me really
changed my life and how I think about my
business in particular and so he's a
mentor and I love checking out his stuff
so both of them are our past you know
they passed away my number three mentors
delivery and still kicking up a storm
and is on the upswing and that's Gary
Vaynerchuk and Gary is he has his own
companies and entrepreneurs the speaker
is a social media expert and I love
watching Gary's keynote presentations
one selfishly because I want to become a
better speaker and so again whatever you
want to get better at find someone who's
one of the best in the world at it and
model what works for them learn from
their success so Gary in my view is one
of the best speakers in the world and I
love watching his stuff every time is a
new presentation I'll consume it and
I'll learn something from it he teaches
me about being passionate and bringing
that to your presentations and really
connecting with the audience on top of
that he's also a social media guy you
know he's written a couple books on it
considered a worldwide expert on it and
the lessons that he teaches there are
really making it personal connecting
with people one on one answering them
being responsive and not just trying to
automate your social media campaigns and
hope that something great is going to
come and that's something I believe in
as well so those are my three
professional business mentors AP
Giannini Steve Jobs Gary Vaynerchuk I
hope you guys will go check them out and
be inspired just like I am
believe those are watching like this
video you can support me by clicking on
the link in the description you can
leave a comment let me know who your
mentors are let me know if they're dead
or alive and why you like them I love to
hear from you and don't forget click on
my face subscribe to the channel thank
you so much I'll see you soon